if Government
naturally wants to buy stuff it can't
afford
what's the best form of government
anarchism
libertarianism so not even go there's
not even armies there's no borders
that's anarchism at least
the smallest possible the smallest
possible the less the best government
would be the least and the debate will
be over that when you think about the
stuff do you think about okay government
is the way it is I as a person that can
generate great ideas how do I operate in
this world or do you also think about
the big picture if we start a new
civilization somewhere on Mars do you
think about like what's the ultimate
form of government
what's uh at least a promising thing to
try
you know um
I have laser eyes on my profile yes
Twitter what does that mean and the
significance of laser eyes is to focus
on the thing that can make a difference
yes and um if I look at the civilization
um I would say
half the problems in the civilization
are due to the fact that our
understanding of economics and money is
defective half 50 I don't know it's
worth 500 trillion dollars worth of
problems like money uh money represents
all the economic energy and the
civilization and it kind of equates to
all the products all the services and
all the assets that we have and we're
ever gonna have so that's half the other
half of the problems in the civilization
are medical and and Military and
political and philosophical and you know
and uh natural
and I think that there are a lot of
different solutions to all those
problems and they're all
they are all uh
uh honorable professions and and they
all Merit a lifetime of consideration
for the specialists in all those areas
I I think that
what I could offer it's constructive is
um
inflation is completely misunderstood
it's a much bigger problem than we
understand it to be we need to introduce
engineering and science techniques into
economics if we want to further the
Human Condition
all government policy is inflationary
you know and another pernicious myth is
uh inflation is always and everywhere a
monetary phenomena so you know a famous
quote by Milton Friedman I believe it's
like it's a monetary phenomena that is
inflation comes from expanding the
currency Supply
it's a nice phrase and it's oftentimes
quoted by people that are anti-inflation
but again it it just signifies a lack of
appreciation of what the issue is
inflation is if I if I had a currency
which was completely non-inflationary if
if I never printed another dollar and if
I eliminated fractional Reserve banking
from the face of the Earth we'd still
have inflation and we'd have inflation
as long as we have government that that
is capable of pursuing any kind of
policies that are in the in them
self-inflationary and generally they all
are so in general
inflationary is the big
characteristic of human nature that
governments collection of groups that
have power over others and allocate
other people's resources
will try to intentionally or not hide
the costs of those allocations like in
some tricky ways whatever the options
ever available
you know hiding the cost is like is like
the the tertiary thing like
the the primary goal is the government
will attempt to do good
right and and that's the fundam that's
the primary problem they will attempt to
do good and they will and they will do
it they will do good imperfectly and
they will create oftentimes uh as much
damage more damage than the good they do
most government policy will be
iatrogenic it will it will create more
harm than good in the pursuit of it but
it is what it is the secondary uh the
secondary issue is they will
unintentionally pay for it by expanding
the currency Supply without realizing
that their uh they're actually paying
for it in in a sub-optimal fashion
they'll collapse their own currencies
while they attempt to do good the the
tertiary issue is they will mismeasure
how badly they're collapsing the
currency
so for example if you go to the Bureau
of Labor Statistics you know and look at
the numbers printed by the FED they'll
say oh it looks like the dollar has lost
95 of its purchasing power over 100
years
okay they sort of fess up there's a
problem but they make it 95 percent loss
over 100 years what they don't do is
realize it's a 99.7 loss over 80 years
so they will mismeasure just the
horrific extent of uh the monetary
policy in pursuit of the foreign policy
and the domestic policy which they they
overestimate
their budget and their means to
accomplish their ends and they
underestimate the cost and and they're
oblivious to the horrific damage that
they do to the civilization because the
mental models that they use that are
conventionally taught are wrong right
the mental model that like it's okay we
can print all this money because the
velocity of the money is low
right because money velocity is a scalar
and inflation is the scalar and we don't
see two percent inflation yet and the
money velocity is low and so it's okay
if we print
trillions of dollars well the money
velocity was immediate
right the velocity of money through the
crypto economy
is 10 000 times faster
than the velocity of money through the
consumer economy
right it's I think Nick pointed out when
you spoke to him he said it takes two
months for a credit card transaction to
settle right so you want to spend a
million dollars in the consumer economy
you can move it six times a year
you you put a million dollars in a gold
gold will sit in a vault for a decade
okay so the velocity of money through
gold is 0.1
you put the money in the stock market
and you can trade it once a week the
settlement is t plus two maybe you get
to two to one leverage you might get to
a money velocity of a hundred a year
in the stock market
you put your money into the crypto
economy and these people are settling
every four hours
and and you know if you're offshore
they're trading with 20x Leverage
so if you if you settle every day and
you trade the 20x leverage you just went
to seven thousand yeah so the veloc the
velocity of the money varies I think the
politicians that they don't really
understand inflation and they don't
understand economic but but you can't
blame them because the economists don't
understand economics because the uh
because if they did they would be
creating
multivariate computer simulations where
they actually put in the price of every
piece of housing in every city in the
world the full array of foods and the
full array of products and the full
array of assets
and then on a monthly basis they would
publish all those results and where and
that's a high bandwidth
requirement
and I I think that people don't really
want to embrace it and and also there's
the most pernicious thing
like there's that phrase you know you
can't tell people what to think but you
can tell them what to think about the
most pernicious thing is is I get you to
misunderstand the phenomena so that even
when it's happening to you you don't
appreciate that it's a bad thing and you
think it's a good thing so if housing
prices are going up 20 percent year over
year and I say this is great for the
American public because most of them are
homeowners then I have I've
misrepresented a phenomena inflation is
20 percent
not seven percent and then I've
misrepresented it as being a positive
rather than a negative
and people will stare at it and you
could even show them their house on fire
and they would perceive it as being
great because it's warming them up and
they're going to save on their heat
costs it does seem that the cruder the
model whether it's economics or their
psychology
the easier it is to weave whatever the
heck narrative you want and not in a
malicious way but just like it's it's
some some kind of like uh emergent
phenomena this narrative thing that we
tell ourselves so you can tell any kind
of story about inflation inflation is
good inflation is bad like the cruder
the model the easier it is to tell a
narrative about it and that's what the
so like if you take an engineering
approach
it's I feel like it becomes more and
more difficult to run away from sort of
a true deep understanding of the
Dynamics of the system
I mean honestly if you went to 100
people on the street you asked them to
define inflation how many would how many
would say it's a vector tracking the
change in price of every product service
asset in the world over time
no not me no if if you if you went to
them and you said
you know uh do you think two percent
inflation a year is good or bad
the majority would probably say well
here it's good you know the majority of
economists would say two percent
inflation a year is good
and of course there's look at the ship
next to us what if I told you that the
ship leaked
two percent right of its volume every
something right the ship is rotting two
percent a year that means the useful
life of the ship is 50 years now
ironically that's true like a wooden
ship had a 50 year to 100 Year life 100
be long 50 years not unlikely so when we
built ships out of wood they had a
useful life of about 50 years and then
they sunk they rotted there's nothing
good about it right you build a ship out
of steel you know and it's zero as
opposed to two percent degradation and
how much better is zero percent versus
two percent well
two percent means you have a useful life
of you know it's half-life of 35 years
two two percent is a half-life of 35
years that's basically the half-life of
money in Gold if I store your life force
in Gold under perfect circumstances you
have a useful life of 35 years
zero percent is a useful life of forever
so zero percent is immortal two percent
is 35 years average life expectancy
so the the idea that you would think the
life expectancy of the currency and the
civilization should be 35 years instead
of forever is is kind of a silly notion
but the tragic notion is it was it was
you know seven into seventy or ten years
it's the money has had a half-life of 10
years except for the fact that in Weak
societies and in Argentina or the like
the half-life of the money is three to
four years in Venezuela one year
so the United States dollar uh and the
United States economic system was the
most successful economic system in the
last hundred years in the world we want
every war we were the world superpower
our currency lost 99.7 percent of its
value and that means horrifically every
other currency
lost everything right in essence the the
other ones were 99.9 except for most
that were 100 because they all
completely failed
and uh you know you've got a you've got
a mainstream economic Community you know
that thinks that inflation is a number
and two percent is desirable
it's it's it's kind of like
you know remember George Washington you
know how he died no
well-meaning Physicians bled him to
death
okay the last thing in the world you
would want to do to a sick person is
bleed them right in the modern world I
think we understand that that oxygen is
carried by the blood cells and and you
know and if uh
you know there's that phrase right uh a
triage phrase what's the first thing you
do in an injury
stop the bleeding single first thing
right you show up after any accident I
look at you stop the bleeding because
you're going to be dead in a matter of
minutes if you bleed out
so
it strikes me as being ironic that
Orthodox conventional wisdom was bleed
the patient to death and this was the
most important patient in the country
maybe in the history of the country and
it's and we bled him to death trying to
help him so when you're actually
inflating the money supply at seven
percent but you're calling it two
percent because you want to help the
economy you're literally bleeding the
the free market to death but the sad
fact is George Washington went along
with it because he thought that they
were going to do him good and the
majority of of uh the society most
companies most most conventional
thinkers you know the working class they
go along with this because they think
that someone has their best interest in
mind and the people that aren't bleeding
them to death believe
they believe that prescription because
their mental models are just so
defective and then an understanding of
energy
and engineering and and uh and the
economics that are at play is uh is
crippled by these mental models but
that's both the bug and the future of
human civilization that ideas take hold
they unite us we believe in them
uh and we make a lot of cool stuff
happen
by
as an average sort of just the fact of
the matter a lot of people believe the
same thing they get together and they
get some [ __ ] done because they believe
that thing and then some ideas can be
really bad and really destructive but on
average the ideas seem to be progressing
in in a direction of good